it turns out all our teachers were wrong
the correct way to count is four five
six one two three seven eight nine well
at least from a certain point of view
Star Wars is known today as a cultural
phenomenon but it wasn't always seen
that way the original film a new hope
was released back in 1977 with little
hope of success by even its creator
George Lucas
according to screen prism Lucas was so
sure of its failure that when it was
released in cinemas he was hiding out in
Hawaii on vacation but Lucas must have
had some belief the movie could be a hit
because buried deep in his mind was a
plan to turn what looked like a
standalone film into a series of movies
and then something incredible happened
it was a new hope then simply titled
Star Wars defied the odds and became a
mega hit of galactic proportions a new
hope was followed by The Empire Strikes
Back in 1980 and Return of the Jedi came
after in 1983 to complete the original
Star Wars trilogy then in 1999 a fourth
Star Wars film was released only it
wasn't a fourth film it was to be the
first one on the Star Wars timeline the
Phantom Menace is in fact episode 1 it
was succeeded by episode 2 Attack of the
Clones in 2002 and episode 3 Revenge of
the Sith in 2005 to comprise a Star Wars
prequel trilogy more films are released
from 2015 to 2019 the force awakens the
last Jedi and the rise of Skywalker
which were sequels to the original three
Star Wars films but why create them in
this order why not make the first Star
Wars trilogy prequels then create two
separate sequel collections the answer
is a lot simpler than its accompanying
question suggests author Michael
Kaminski writes in the secret history of
Star Wars that Lucas decided to start
with the fourth episode quote due to
technical and storytelling reasons he
further explained Lucas had a massive
expensive epic on his hands and divided
the story into three separate films he
had also developed a backstory for his
elaborate tale which together totaled
six chapters and sought to make Episode
four first due to technical and
storytelling reasons when the film by
some miracle went into production it was
beset by problems of all kinds and Lucas
was sure it would
be a failure and was shocked when it
became the biggest sensation of the year
Lucas himself has collaborated this
claim he admitted the Star Wars series
started out as a movie that ended up
being so big that I took each act and
cut it into its own movie when I first
did Star Wars I did it as a big piece it
was like a big script it was way too big
to make into a movie so I took the first
third of it which is basically the first
act and I turned that into what was the
original Star Wars the story of the New
Hope gave no context of the world in the
film throwing viewers straight into the
action without any background knowledge
doing so would later give Lucas the
opportunity to go back and provide some
context in the prequels from the release
of the first Star Wars film there was
talk that Lucas had three trilogies in
mind one of which would be a prequel
trilogy that would deal with the
political background needed for the
Empire to become what it was in the
original movie Lucas always knew he
wanted to create an entire galaxy far
far away not just a standalone film
there's plenty of evidence of that in a
new hope with references to the Clone
Wars the Jedi Order and the Kessel run
hinting at an untold story it took a
number of different drafts of the first
Star Wars film before the story of Luke
Skywalker a poor farm boy from Tatooine
who discovers he has Jedi powers and
joins a band of rebels against an evil
dictatorship in the form of the Empire
took shape leaving other characters by
the wayside to have their stories told
later
Lucas kept them in the bank and put some
of his ideas into the film and passing
mention to give that backstory mace
Wendy who became mace windu in the final
story an Anakin star killer later Anakin
Skywalker are among the characters who
were initially meant to be in the first
film and Lucas's early drafts both
appear in the Star Wars prequels
although Anakin was technically part of
the original trilogy given that he
eventually transforms into Darth Vader
Lucas had a pretty specific vision in
mind for a new hope he wanted the film
to fade in with audiences making it feel
like they were coming in half way
through a larger story he would pave the
way for Lucas to be able to turn the
film into a full movie series and he
already had the groundwork laid for the
backstory he would need to tell but what
about the final trilogy of the Skywalker
saga headlined by the powerful young ray
might be wondering the Lucas already had
it set in his mind to make Episode seven
through nine way back when he hadn't yet
mapped the actual story that would
unfold in those three films what he did
know was that he wanted the original
three heroes to make a return
according to comic book calm Lucas got
his wish on that final point giving them
a chance to say their final goodbyes as
the Skywalker saga comes to an end with
the release of the rise of Skywalker on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]